all right one division this week this
was the
well i'm going to re i was going to call
it the most compelling episode
that's not the word it's the most
satisfying episode of one division all
right first of all spoiler warning for
juan division this week was this episode
four yeah it's totally episode four so
spoilers for one division this week and
we're going to get right into it because
you've been warned about spoiling all
those answers where i was like i'd like
a little more answers other than we're
in a sitcom world cuz we got those
not in a trickle all at once this show
was like here's the episode
folks here's all of it so it starts out
after
everyone comes back from the snap the
blip you know the thanos thing everyone
got
snapped away and so when they came back
because we didn't see that we saw
after they came back and they all threw
down and fought but this shows
when people reform what happened
starts out with monica rambo who is the
little girl from
from captain marvel because you don't
just make an extraterrestrial superhero
friend when you were a kid and not you
know kind of
get into it all when you grow up elliot
from et did not have a normal life when
he grew up no his career path
he got into some crazy stuff i promise
probably smoking a lot of pot in a
trailer
trying to tell everybody out there on
his little podcast
that aliens are real elliott from bt was
on joe rogan
that's a fact so anyhow she's come back
she's come back to work she works for
swords sword we've seen glimpses and
logos throughout wandavision so now it's
i do got asked though like
where were they i suppose these are also
answers we'll get going forward
but in reality it's a production thing
they were like all right we're gonna do
avengers with shield and you know
we'll start out there and we'll expand
it as it goes there were a lot of
situations where sword would have been
pretty helpful
and they just kind of weren't there
possible for the sake of the mcu world
sword got a lot more funding after
shield was compromised by hydra so
now we have swords so yeah monica rambo
and another agent were like there's
supposed to be a town here
and there's not so they need to find out
why they can't find
the town of storybrooke and for a while
in one division i was like what does
this remind me of this town that's
hidden
and no one knows there's a town there
because there's not a town there to them
but there's a town there
for the it's story broke from once upon
a time that's what i think of anyway
maybe scarlet witch should have done
that when she blasted monica out of the
reality she would have been like oh
magic comes with a prize deary
so sword brings in a crew of different
specialists including kat dennings who
we haven't seen in a while
i'm glad she's still a part of it i'm
glad you're still part of the mcu it's
like you see that sometimes in the mcu
it's like that was a supporting
character
we've moved on now it did kind of crack
me up and she starts seeing a broadcast
she's like i need a tv
as in an old one not flat easier way to
do that be like hey room full of fellow
nerds
which one of you is a retro gamer oh
that's a lot of hands
it's a lot of crts that are definitely
available right now
i'm just saying man we nerds we we love
those crts but this episode for me was
really satisfying not just because of
the answers i got not just because of
the connections you see
going back you know when it was like
wanda what's happening who's doing this
do you want to we now see what happened
what people
outside of the town reality bubble what
they were doing to try to connect with
her and find out what was happening but
i found it satisfying for that reason
they were asking the same questions like
wait there's a sitcom
why so i like seeing the characters
outside the fake one division reality
and their reality have the same
questions as i do
as a person outside the reality within
the reality misery loves company but
it's not just misery it's just
everything loves company misery loves
company confusion loves company
happiness loves company
everything loves company every emotional
state so yeah satisfying to see but the
thing i actually loved most is seeing
the characters watch wanda vision in the
same way
we're watching one division it's just it
it forms some connection between that
and the concept of higher dimensional
beings watching
us you know if they're watching us it
probably does feel like a sitcom to them
and then i saw a connection between
something i
kind of think about is gonna be a bit of
a tangent anyway a tangent from one
division but it still
is how i process this episode so i guess
it's relevant if it's me talking about
this episode which i think is probably
what
demons ghosts black masses all these
things that
the stories that we have if they're real
and not just
psychological plays not just something
made up in people's minds don't believe
in demons or ghosts but it
probably would be some higher
dimensional beings
trying to interact with our third
dimension but they can't we wouldn't see
them as they are we would see them
as we can per our third dimensional
reality kind of like if there are
two-dimensional beings and we try to
interact with them and we put our finger
into their realm it's a two-dimensional
thing so they're not going to see a
finger they're just going to see a line
that forms in front of them and then
goes away because they can't see the
three-dimensional object on a
two-dimensional plane they can only see
two dimensions of this three-dimensional
object in worlds of you know
hauntings that aren't just crickety
pipes and old houses you know black
masses that grow in corners
if they're real they probably are that
these higher dimensional beings trying
to interact with us but it's just
hard for them to do that's if you know
that's if
that's what that is but i lend more
credence to that possibility than you
know
ghosts and ghouls and goblins and things
and in the end if they're watching us it
probably is a lot like the agents of
sword watching this wand division sitcom
i just
i got a kick out of that and i like the
fact that that connection hit me it
seems like a stretch for this episode of
wand division to make me think of
that bit of a leap but as someone who
does talk movies
this is something i think about when i'm
not talking movies so it's always
enjoyable when something that
is entertainment that i make videos on
kind of
forms that connection for me even if it
might not have been intentional it's
just i enjoy it what happened to the
beekeeper guy though this whole hazmat
suit turned into a beekeeper outfit and
the rope
that he was attached to turned into a
jump rope because when things go into
this one division world they're
now accurate to the time so that's what
the beekeeper was but
as much as she's like nope and she you
know rewinds the broadcast she goes back
it's like nope we're going to go ahead
and splice it
and now that didn't happen what happened
to the beekeeper guy
is he now outside the world because when
they're watching wanda vision looking at
it they're aware that these splices in
reality happen did the guy just
disappear
hope he's all right and in the end we
get the answer after monica was blasted
out she's like
she quite literally turns to the camera
and says it's wanda it's all wanda so
the insinuation is wanda
is doing this she's doing this probably
because she wants to hang out with her
dead boyfriend
reality out there sucks for her it does
deal with cosmic microwave background
radiation which is the echo of the big
bang and they're detecting the same
energy signature in this one division
reality so if i'm hearing it right she's
using the same energy that created our
universe to create her
one division reality so it's not just an
illusion
it is literally a little bubble reality
she's created it's a reality
on top or inside of another reality
or it's mephisto you know that theory is
still out there it's peter
fonda i don't know as much as we've been
told it's wanda it's all wanda
we still have a few episodes left in the
words of the great kane
fate promises more twists before this
drama unfolds
completely in the end this episode of
wand division i really dug it just for
the execution of people watching a
reality
and i just that makes me think about our
reality maybe that wasn't the mcu's
intention
but that's that's what i liked about it
maybe it was and i don't give the mcu
enough credit i don't know i will say if
next week we just go
back to the wanda vision world and we're
just living sitcom life again that's
gonna feel like a backslide so
i hope they balance it out don't know
but this episode this was some solid
payoff i dug it alright so one division
episode four have you seen it what did
you think about it whatever you thought
comment below
let me know and as always if you like
what you've seen here and you want to
see more click right here to see more
you